el valor de 3 en el número 53 1946 es
cuántas veces el valor del 3 en 27 mil
381 por la posición del 13 en esta
cantidad está en unidades decenas
centenas millares esta es la posición de
los millares y aquí está en unidades
decenas centenas está en los 100
entonces este 3 es 10 veces el valor de
este otro 3 ya que está un lugar hacia
la izquierda conforme avanzamos una
posición hacia la izquierda
el factor va a aumentar en 10 por lo que
este 3 al pasarlo aquí es de otro lugar
como en esta cantidad se aumenta su
valor en 10
veamos comprobar la respuesta en efecto
aquí está hagamos otro ejercicio el
valor de 7 en el número 7 1865 es
cuántas veces el valor del 7 en 2.375
bueno tenemos aquí este 7 está en
unidades decenas vale 70 aquí el 7 está
unidades decenas centenas millares el
7.000 son dos lugares de diferencia por
lo que es cien veces mayor
ese siete aquí que este siete acá muy
bien hagamos un problema más el valor de
4 en el número 47 1.251 es cuántas veces
el valor de 4 en 493 mil 252 ok aquí el
4 está en unidades desde las centenas
millares decenas de millar cuarenta mil
pero el 4 acá está en unidades decenas
centenas millares decenas de millares
centenas de millares este es 400.000 por
lo que este 4 vale más por posición que
el 4 de acá este es una décima parte
porque nada más hay un lugar de
diferencia hacia la izquierda entre este
4 y este 4 de acá vamos a ver la
respuesta está bien
una décima parte del valor del 4 en esta
cantidad nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo